para llevarme a un lugar seguro
después de un accidente de auto que me pudo haber matado.
Y todo esto me dejó realmente conmocionada, obviamente,
pero también me dejó con esa curiosidad y esa necesidad persistente
de entender por qué lo hizo,
¿qué motivos le impulsaron a tomar la decisión
a quien yo debo la vida,
a arriesgar su propia vida para salvar la vida de un desconocido?
En otras palabras, ¿qué genera la capacidad
de él o de cualquier otra persona para el altruismo?
Pero primero les contaré lo que pasó.
Esa noche, yo tenía 19 años
y conducía a mi casa en Tacoma, Washington,
por la carretera interestatal 5,
cuando un perrito salió corriendo ante mi auto.
E hice exactamente lo que no se debe hacer,
que es desviarse para evitarlo.
Y descubrí por qué no se debe hacer eso.
Golpeé al perro de todos modos,
el auto hizo un trompo,
y luego dio tumbos de un lado al otro de la autopista,
hasta que finalmente terminó en el carril rápido de la autopista
enfrentado hacia atrás al tráfico que venía
y luego el motor se apagó.
Estaba segura de que en ese momento estaba a punto de morir también,
pero no lo hice
gracias a la acción de un hombre valiente
que tuvo que tomar la decisión
en una fracción de segundo de ver mi auto varado
hacerse a un lado y correr por cuatro carriles de la autopista
en la oscuridad
para salvar mi vida.
Y luego, después de hacer que funcionara de nuevo mi auto
me llevó a un lugar seguro y se aseguró de que iba a estar bien,
él salió de nuevo.
Ni siquiera me dijo su nombre,
y estoy bastante segura de que me olvidé de decir gracias.
Así que antes de seguir,
realmente quiero dedicar un momento,
parar y decir gracias a ese extraño.
(Aplausos)
Les digo todo esto
porque los acontecimientos de esa noche cambiaron el curso de mi vida.
Me hice investigadora en psicología,
y he dedicado mi trabajo a comprender la capacidad humana de cuidar a los demás.
¿De dónde viene, y cómo se desarrolla,
y cuáles son las formas extremas que puede adoptar?
Estas preguntas son muy importantes para entender los aspectos básicos
de la naturaleza social humana.
Mucha gente, esto atañe a todos
desde filósofos y economistas hasta la gente común,
cree que la naturaleza humana es fundamentalmente egoísta,
que solo estamos realmente motivados por nuestro propio bienestar.
Pero si eso es cierto, ¿por qué personas, como el extraño que me rescató,
hacen cosas desinteresados, como ayudar a otras personas
arriesgándose ellas mismas?
Responder a esta pregunta
requiere explorar las raíces de actos extraordinarios de altruismo,
y lo que podría diferenciar a las personas
que hacen este tipo de actos de otras personas.
Sin embargo, hasta hace poco, se ha trabajado poco este tema.
Las acciones del hombre que me rescató
cumplieron con la definición más estricta de altruismo,
que es un comportamiento costoso y voluntario
motivado por el deseo de ayudar a otra persona.
Así que es un acto desinteresado para beneficiar solo al otro.
¿Qué podría explicar una acción como esa?
Una respuesta es la compasión, obviamente,
un factor clave del altruismo.
Pero entonces la pregunta es:
¿por qué algunas personas parecen tener más de esto que otros?
Y la respuesta puede ser que los cerebros de las personas altamente altruistas
son fundamentalmente diferentes.
Pero para encontrar la diferencia
empecé desde el extremo opuesto,
con psicópatas.
Un enfoque común para la comprensión de los aspectos básicos
de la naturaleza humana, como el deseo de ayudar a otras personas,
consiste en estudiar personas en las que no se encuentra ese deseo,
y los psicópatas son exactamente ese grupo.
La psicopatía es un trastorno del desarrollo
con orígenes fuertemente genéticos,
y el resultado es una personalidad fría e indiferente con tendencia
a involucrarse en comportamientos antisociales y, a veces, muy violentos.
Mis colegas y yo en el Instituto Nacional de Salud Mental de EE.UU.
llevamos a cabo algunas de las primeras investigaciones con imágenes del cerebro
de los adolescentes psicopáticos.
Nuestros hallazgos y los hallazgos de otros investigadores ahora
han demostrado que las personas psicópatas
son bastante propensas a presentar tres características.
Primero, aunque no son insensibles en general a las emociones de otras personas,
son insensibles a señales de que otras personas están en peligro.
Y, en particular,
tienen dificultades para reconocer expresiones faciales de miedo como ésta.
Y las expresiones de miedo transmiten necesidad urgente y angustia emocional,
y, por lo general, provocan la compasión y el deseo de ayudar
en las personas que los ven.
Por esta razón, las personas que tienden a carecer de compasión,
también tienden a ser insensibles a estas señales.
La parte del cerebro
más importante para reconocer expresiones de miedo
se llama la amígdala.
Hay casos muy raros de personas que carecen por completo de amígdala,
y tienen profundamente deteriorado el reconocimiento de expresiones de miedo.
Y mientras que los adultos y niños sanos,
por lo general, muestran grandes picos en la actividad de la amígdala
cuando ven expresiones de miedo,
las amígdalas de los psicópatas son hipofuncionales ante estas expresiones.
A veces no reaccionan en absoluto,
lo que hace tener dificultades para detectar estas señales.
Por último, las amígdalas de psicópatas son más pequeñas que la media
en alrededor de 18 % o 20 %.
Todos estos hallazgos son fiables y robustos,
y muy interesantes.
Pero recuerden que mi principal interés
no es entender por qué las personas no se preocupan por los demás.
sino comprender por qué sí lo hacen.
Así que la pregunta real es,
¿podría el altruismo sin igual,
que es lo contrario de la psicopatía
en términos de compasión y deseo de ayudar a otras personas,
emerger de un cerebro que es también lo contrario de la psicopatía?
¿Una especie de cerebro antipsicopático,
más capaz de reconocer el miedo de otras personas,
con un amígdala más reactiva a esta expresión
y tal vez más grande de lo normal?
Como muestra mi investigación,
las tres cosas son ciertas.
Y lo descubrimos
probando una población de altruistas verdaderamente extraordinarios.
Se trata de personas que han dado sus propios riñones
a un completo desconocido.
Estas son las personas que se han ofrecido a someterse a una cirugía
para que se les extirpe uno de sus propios riñones sanos
para que sea trasplantado en un extraño muy enfermo
que no conocían y que puede que nunca lleguen a conocer.
"¿Por qué alguien lo hace?" Es una pregunta muy común.
Y la respuesta puede ser
que los cerebros de estos altruistas extraordinarios
tienen ciertas características especiales.
Son mejores para reconocer el miedo de otras personas.
Son, literalmente, mejor para detectar cuando alguien está en peligro.
Esto puede ser porque su amígdala es más reactiva a estas expresiones.
Y recuerden, esta es la misma parte del cerebro que vimos que
era hipofuncional en psicópatas.
Y, por último, sus amígdalas son más grandes de lo normal,
en alrededor de un 8 %.
Así que, lo que sugieren estos datos
es la existencia de una continuidad de preocupación por el mundo
eso está anclado en un extremo por personas altamente psicopáticas,
y en el otro por las personas que son muy compasivas
que las lleva a actos de altruismo extremo.
Pero debo añadir que lo marca la diferencia en altruistas extraordinarios,
no es solo el hecho de ser más compasivos que el promedio.
Lo son,
pero lo que aún es más inusual en ellos,
es que son compasivos y altruistas
no solo hacia las personas de su propio círculo íntimo
de amigos y familiares.
Porque sentir compasión por la gente que te gusta y con los que te identificas
no es extraordinario.
En verdad la compasión extraordinaria de los altruistas
se extiende mucho más allá de ese círculo,
incluso más allá de su círculo más amplio de conocidos,
a las personas que están fuera de su círculo social,
a los extraños,
como el hombre que me rescató.
Y he tenido la oportunidad de preguntar a muchos altruistas donantes de riñón
cómo se las arreglan para generar un amplio círculo de compasión tal
que estaban dispuestos a dar a un completo desconocido su riñón.
Y he detectado que es una pregunta para ellos muy difícil de responder.
Yo digo: "¿Cómo es que estás dispuesto a hacer esto
si tantas otras personas no lo hacen?
Eres uno de menos de 2000 estadounidenses
que ha dado un riñón a un desconocido.
¿Qué es lo que te hace tan especial?"
Y ¿qué dicen?
Ellos dicen: "Nada.
No hay nada especial en mí.
Soy igual que todos los demás".
Y creo que eso es en realidad una respuesta realmente reveladora,
porque sugiere que los círculos de estos altruistas no se parecen a esto,
sino a esto.
No tienen ningún centro.
Estos altruistas, literalmente, no piensan en sí mismos
como en el centro de cualquier cosa,
por ser mejor o intrínsecamente más importantes que los demás.
Al preguntar a una altruista, por qué donar su riñón tenía sentido para ella,
dijo: "Porque no se trata de mí".
Otro dijo:
"No soy diferente. No soy único.
Tu estudio demostrará que soy igual que tú".
Creo que la mejor descripción de esta increíble carencia de egocentrismo
es la humildad,
que es que la calidad que, en palabras de San Agustín,
hace a los hombres ángeles.
¿Y por qué es eso?
Es porque, si no hay un centro de su círculo,
no puede haber anillos interiores o anillos exteriores,
nadie que sea más o menos digno de su atención y compasión
que nadie.
Y creo que esto es lo que realmente distingue a los altruistas extraordinarios
de la persona promedio.
Pero también creo que esa es una visión del mundo que es alcanzable por muchos
y, tal vez, incluso, por la mayoría de la gente.
Y creo esto, porque a nivel social,
ya están ocurriendo expansiones de altruismo y compasión en todas partes.
El psicólogo Steven Pinker y otros han demostrado
que en todo el mundo las personas están cada vez menos dispuestas
a aceptar que se amplíe el creciente círculo de sufrimiento de los demás,
lo que ha llevado a la disminución de todo tipo de crueldad y violencia,
desde el maltrato a animales, a la violencia doméstica,
hasta la pena capital.
Lo que lleva al aumento en todo tipo de altruismo.
Hace cien años, la gente habría pensado que era absurdo
lo normal y común que es
la donación de sangre y médula ósea
para ayudar a extraños en la actualidad.
¿Es posible que dentro de cien años
la gente piense que donar un riñón a un desconocido
es tan normal y común
como creemos que es la donación de sangre y médula ósea hoy?
Tal vez.
¿Qué está en la raíz de todos estos cambios sorprendentes?
En parte, parece ser
el aumento de la riqueza y el nivel de vida.
A medida que las sociedades se hacen más ricas y mejores,
la gente parece dirigir su foco de atención hacia fuera,
y, como resultado, aumenta todo tipo de altruismo hacia los extraños,
desde los voluntarios, a donaciones de caridad,
hasta incluso donaciones de riñón altruistas.
Pero todos estos cambios también arrojan
un resultado extraño y paradójico,
porque, aún cuando el mundo se convierte en un lugar mejor y más humano,
hay una percepción muy común de que se está convirtiendo en peor
y más cruel, lo que no es cierto.
Y no sé exactamente por qué esto es,
pero yo creo que puede ser que ahora sabemos mucho más
del sufrimiento de extraños en lugares distantes,
y porque ahora importa mucho más
el sufrimiento de esos extraños distantes.
Pero lo que está claro es los cambios que observamos, muestran
que las raíces del altruismo y la compasión
se encuentran más allá de la naturaleza humana, como la crueldad y la violencia,
tal vez incluso más,
y mientras que algunas personas parecen ser inherentemente más sensibles
al sufrimiento de aquellos más distantes,
Realmente creo que la capacidad de eclipsarse a uno mismo
del centro del círculo
y ampliar el círculo de compasión hacia afuera para incluir incluso extraños
está al alcance de casi todo el mundo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)